IT Verbs.
Don't get lost in the English world of information technology.
Software developers program in different languages.
Programmers can command a computer to perform tasks.
This program can help you calculate the size of an object.
Update your software often to avoid bugs.
I use Google's search engine to search for information.
You need to run a program before you can use it.
Send me an email if you need more information.
First, you must install the program on your laptop.
You can add information by inserting it.
You can copy information by writing it to a disk.
Don't delete the file! Just edit the text and photo.
Find the information you want by filtering it.